[Music]
as a particle physicist I study the
elementary particles and how they
interact on the most fundamental level
for most of my research career I've been
using accelerators such as the electron
accelerator at Stanford University just
up the road to study things on the
smallest scale but more recently I've
been turning my attention to the
universe on the largest scale because as
I'll explain to you the questions on the
smallest in the largest scale are
actually very connected so I'm going to
tell you about our 21st century view of
the universe what it's made of and what
the big questions in the physical
sciences are at least some of the big
questions so recently we have realized
that the ordinary matter in the universe
and by ordinary matter
I mean you okay me the planets the Stars
the galaxies the ordinary matter makes
up only a few percent of the content of
the universe
almost a quarter or approximately a
quarter of the matter in the universe is
stuff that's invisible by invisible I
mean it doesn't absorb in the
electromagnetic spectrum it doesn't emit
in the electromagnetic spectrum it
doesn't reflect it doesn't interact with
the electromagnetic spectrum which is
what we use to detect things doesn't
interact at all so how do we know it's
there we know it's there by its
gravitational effects in fact this dark
matter dominates the gravitational
effects in the universe on a large scale
and I'll be telling you about the
evidence for that
what about the rest of the pie the rest
of the pie is a very mysterious
substance called dark energy more about
that later okay so for now let's turn to
the evidence for dark matter in these
galaxies especially in a spiral galaxy
like this most of the mass of the stars
is concentrated in the middle of the
galaxy this huge mass of all these stars
keeps stars in circular orbits in the
galaxy
so we have these stars going around in
circles like this as you can imagine
even if you know that no physics this
should be intuitive okay that stars that
are closer to the mass in the middle
will be rotating at a higher speed than
those that are fahrt further out here
okay so what you would expect
is that if you measured the orbital
speed of the stars that they should be
slower on the edges than on the inside
in other words if we measured speed as a
function of distance this is the only
time I'm going to show a graph okay we
would expect that it goes down as the
distance increases from the center of
the galaxy when those measurements are
made instead what we find is that the
speed is basically constant as a
function of distance if it's constant
that means that the stars out here are
we are feeling the gravitational effects
of matter that we do not see in fact
this galaxy and every other galaxy
appears to be embedded in a cloud of
this invisible dark matter and this
cloud of matter is much more spherical
than the galaxies themselves and it
extends over much what wider range than
the galaxy so we see the galaxy and
fixate on that but it's actually a cloud
of dark matter that's dominating the
structure and the dynamics of this
galaxy galaxies themselves are not
strewn randomly in space they tend to
cluster and this is an example of a very
extra famous cluster the Coma Cluster
and there are thousands of galaxies in
this cluster there the white fuzzy
elliptical things here so these galaxies
clusters we take a snapshot now we take
a snapshot in a decade it'll look
identical but these galaxies are
actually moving at extremely high speeds
they're moving around in this
gravitational potential well of this
cluster okay so all these galaxies are
moving we can measure the speeds of
these galaxies their orbital velocities
and figure out how much mass is in this
cluster and again what we find is that
there is much more mass there than can
be accounted for by the galaxies that we
see or if we look in other parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum we see that
there's a lot of gas in this cluster as
well but that cannot account for the
mass either in fact there appears to be
about ten times as much mass here in the
form of this invisible or dark matter as
there is in the ordinary matter okay it
would be nice if we could see this dark
matter a little bit more directly I'm
just putting this big blue blob on there
okay to try to remind you that it's
there can we see it more visually yes we
can and so let me lead you through how
we can do this so here is an observer
they could
I could be a telescope and suppose
there's a galaxy out here in the
universe how do we see that galaxy array
of light leaves the galaxy and travels
through the universe for perhaps
billions of years before it enters the
telescope or your eye now how do we
deduce where the galaxy is well we
deduce it by the direction that the Ray
is traveling as it enters our eye right
we say the ray of light came this way
the galaxy must be there okay
now suppose I put in the middle a
cluster of galaxies and don't forget the
dark matter okay now if we consider a
different ray of light one going off
like this we now need to take into
account what Einstein predicted when he
developed general relativity and that
was that the gravitational field due to
mass will deflect not only the
trajectory of particles but will deflect
light itself so this light ray will not
continue in a straight line but would
rather band and could end up going into
our eye where will this observer see the
galaxy you can respond up right we
extrapolate backwards and say the galaxy
is up here is there any other ray of
light that could make it into the
observers eye from that galaxy yes great
I see people going down like this so a
ray of light could go down be bent up
into the observers eye and the observer
sees a ray of light here now take into
account the fact that we live in a
three-dimensional universe okay
three-dimensional space are there any
other rays of light that could make it
into the eye yes the Rays would lie on a
I like to say yeah on a cone so there's
a whole array of light rays of light on
a cone that will all be bent by that
cluster and make it into the observers
eye if there's a cone of light coming
into my eye what do I see a circle a
ring it's called an Einstein ring
Einstein predicted that okay now it'll
only be a perfect ring if the source the
deflector and the eyeball in this case
are all in a perfectly straight line if
they're slightly skewed we'll see a
different image now you can do an
experiment tonight over the reception
okay
to figure out what that image will look
like because it turns out that there is
a
kind of lens that we can devise that has
the right shape to produce this kind of
effect we call this gravitational
lensing and so this is your instrument
okay but ignore the top part it's the
base that I want you to concentrate okay
so actually at home whenever we break a
wineglass I save the bottom take it over
to the machine shop we shave it off and
I have a little gravitational lens okay
so it's got the right shape to produce
the lensing and so the next thing you
need to do in your experiment is I grab
a napkin I grabbed a piece of graph
paper I'm a physicist so a napkin draw a
little model galaxy in the milk and now
put the lens over the galaxy and what
you'll find is that you will see a ring
an Einstein ring now move the base off
to the side and the ring will split up
into arcs okay
and you can put it on top of any image
on the graph paper you can see how all
the the lines on the graph paper have
been distorted and again this is a kind
of an accurate model of what happens
with the gravitational lensing okay so
the question is do we see this in the
sky do we see arcs in the sky when we
look at say a cluster of galaxies and
the answer is yes and so here's an image
from the Hubble Space Telescope many of
the images you are seeing earlier from
the Hubble Space Telescope well first of
all for the golden shaped galaxies those
are the galaxies in the cluster they're
the ones that are embedded in that sea
of dark matter that are causing the
bending of the light to cause these
optical illusions or mirages practically
of the background galaxies so the
streaks that you see all these streaks
are actually distorted images of
galaxies that are much further away so
what we can do then is based on how much
distortion we see in those images we can
calculate how much mass there must be in
this cluster and it's an enormous amount
of mass and also you can tell by eye by
looking at this that these arcs are not
centered on individual galaxies they are
centered on some more Matta's spread out
structure and that is the dark matter
that is being that is in which the
cluster is embedded okay so this is the
closest you can get to kind of seeing at
least the effects of the dark matter
with your naked eye okay so a quick
review then
ok2say that you're following so the
evidence that we have that a quarter of
the universe is dark matter this
gravitationally attracting stuff is that
galaxies the speeds with which stars
orbit and galaxies is much too large it
must be embedded in dark matter the
speed with which galaxies within
clusters are orbiting is much too large
it must be embedded in dark matter and
we see these gravitational lensing
effects these distortions that say that
again
clusters are embedded in dark matter
okay so now let's turn to dark energy so
to understand the evidence for dark
energy we need to discuss something that
Stephen Hawking referred to in the
previous session and that is the fact
that space itself is expanding so if we
imagine a section of our infinite
universe okay and so I've put down four
spiral galaxies okay and imagine that
you put down a set of tape measures okay
so every line on here corresponds to a
tape measure horizontal or vertical for
measuring where things are if you could
do this what you would find that with
each passing day each passing year each
passing billions of years okay
the distance between galaxies is getting
greater and it's not because galaxies
are moving away from each other through
space they're not necessarily moving
through space they are moving away from
each other because space itself is
getting bigger okay that's what the
expansion of the universe or space means
so they're moving further apart now and
what Stephen Hawking mentioned as well
is that after the Big Bang space
expanded at a very rapid rate
but because gravitationally attracting
matter is embedded in this space it
tends to slow down the expansion of the
space okay so the expansion slows down
with time so in the last century okay
people debated about whether this
expansion of space would continue
forever whether it would slow down you
know will be slowing down but continue
forever slowed down and stopped
asymptotically stopped or slowed down
stop and then reverse so it's start to
contract again so a little
over a decade ago two groups of
physicists and astronomers set out to
measure the rate at which the expansion
of space was slowing down okay by how
much last is expanding today compared to
say a couple billion years ago the
startling answer to this question okay
from these experiments was that space is
expanding at a faster rate today than it
was a few billion years ago okay so the
expansion of space is actually speeding
up this was a completely surprising
result there is no persuasive
theoretical argument for why this should
happen okay no one was predicting ahead
of time this is what's going to be found
it was the opposite of what was expected
so we need something to be able to
explain that now it turns out in the
mathematics you can put it in as a term
that's an energy but it's just
completely different type of energy from
anything we've ever seen before we call
it dark energy and it has this effect of
causing space to expand but we don't
have a good motivation for putting it in
there at this point okay so it's really
unexplained as to why we need to put it
in now so at this point then what I want
to really emphasize to you is that first
of all dark matter and dark energy are
completely different things okay there
are really two mysteries out there as to
what what makes up most of the universe
and they have very different effects
dark matter because it gravitationally
attracts it tends to encourage the
growth of structure okay so clusters of
galaxies will tend to form because of
all this gravitational attraction dark
energy on the other hand is putting more
and more space between the galaxies
makes it the gravitational attraction
between them decrease and so it impedes
the growth of structure so by looking at
things like clusters of galaxies and how
they their number density how many there
are as a function of time we can learn
about how dark matter and dark energy
compete against each other in structure
forming in terms of dark matter I said
that we don't have any you know really
persuasive argument for dark energy do
we have anything for dark matter and
the answer is yes we have well motivated
candidates for the dark matter now what
do I mean by what well motivated I mean
that we have mathematically consistent
theories that were actually introduced
to explain a completely different
phenomenon okay things that I haven't
even talked about that each predict the
existence of a very weakly interacting
new particle so this is exactly what you
want in physics where a prediction comes
out of a mathematically consistent
theory that was actually developed for
something else but we don't know if
either of those are actually the Dark
Matter candidate okay one or both who
knows or it could be something
completely different now we look for
these dark matter particles because
after all they are here in the room okay
and they didn't come in the door they
just pass through anything they could
come through the building through the
earth there so non interacting so one
way to look for them is to build
detectors that are extremely sensitive
to a dark matter particle coming through
and bumping it so a crystal that will
ring if that happens so one of my
colleagues up the road and his
collaborators have built such a detector
and they've put it deep down in an iron
mine in Minnesota okay deep under the
ground in fact in the last couple of
days announced the most sensitive
results so far they haven't seen
anything okay but it puts limits on what
the mass and the interaction strength of
these dark matter particles are there's
going to be a satellite telescope
launched later this year and it will
look towards the middle of the galaxy to
see if we can see dark matter particles
annihilating and producing gamma rays
that could be detected with this the
Large Hadron Collider a particle physics
accelerator that will be turning on
later this year it is possible that dark
matter particles might be produced at
the Large Hadron Collider now because
they are so non interactive they will
actually escape the detector so their
signature will be missing energy okay
now unfortunately there's a lot of new
physics whose signature could be missing
energy so it'll be hard to tell the
difference and finally for future
endeavors there are telescopes being
designed specifically to address the
questions of dark matter and dark energy
ground-based telescope and there are
three space base
telescopes they're in competition right
now to be launched to investigate dark
matter and dark energy so in terms of
the big questions what is dark matter
what is dark energy big questions facing
physics and I'm sure you have lots of
questions which I very much look forward
to addressing over the next 72 hours
while I'm here okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
often when things are allowed the
freedom to take shape
they tend to reshape everything the
all-new BMW x6